je me disais ça vous dirait d'aller je
sais pas d'aller prendre un verre
d'accord un café là tout de suite oui là
tout de suite
je vais bien me tenir voilà
[Musique]
je sais que ça peut paraître un peu
dingue mais je crois que ça pourrait
être la bonne femme
elle est vraiment géniale vous verrez
des nouvelles la gosté je parie qu'elle
a même pas eu tes textos pour son
travail
je vais à Londres
[Musique]
vous savez tout compris c'est une
attention romantique c'est formidable
mon petit monsieur 8000 km pour faire la
surprise à une demoiselle que vous
n'avez vu qu'une seule fois surtout si
c'est elle qui vous agace et
elle m'a pas gusté elle m'a pas encore
pris son forfait pour les appels
internationaux ah d'accord
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qui se passe
est-ce que tu peux marcher école
j'ai rien compris ils arrêtaient pas de
me parler du taxman il t'en parler du
taxi le taxi
c'est toi le taxi
c'est pas vrai
kidnapper torturer tout ça après une
seule soirée
c'est toi qui a voulu aller à Londres
une attention romantique
fais passer la photo à tous les
chasseurs de prime sur ce continent un
million pour la trouver vivante
ça nous dépasse autant toi que moi
vous n'avez jamais songé qu'il pouvait
être un agent payé pour compromettre
votre mission
alors tu es qui
je suis le petit copain
[Musique]
ta confiance en moi encore une de tes
blagues à la con